the fall of kabul to the taliban marked
an abrupt end to america's longest war
in nearly 20 years of fighting more than
2 400 american service members lost
their lives 20 000 were wounded the war
cost american taxpayers about one
trillion dollars or 136 million dollars
per day
those costs are the results of two
decades of decision making in washington
decisions that could have changed the
outcome of the war and the future
our mission in afghanistan was never
supposed to have been nation-building
president joe biden is the fourth
commander-in-chief to oversee the war in
afghanistan
his decision to withdraw america's
remaining forces by the end of the month
led to scenes of chaos still unfolding
at kabul's airport
the conflict began just weeks after the
9 11 terror attacks president george w
bush said the mission was to capture or
kill bin laden and to go after al qaeda
and the taliban these carefully targeted
actions are designed to disrupt the use
of afghanistan
as a terrorist base of operations but by
the next year president bush called for
the reconstruction of afghanistan and by
the time barack obama was elected
america found itself years into a second
war this time in iraq
president obama authorized a troop surge
more than tripling the number of
americans in afghanistan to stabilize
the government and build security forces
the date
for us to
have completed our drawdown
will not change
troop levels later declined but obama
did not need his pledge to withdraw all
but a small force by 2017.
a peace deal signed last year by the
trump administration and the taliban
began the process of withdrawing the
last american troops from afghanistan
this is a country that really was a
foreign culture in a foreign country
that we didn't understand washington
post investigative journalist craig
whitlock is the author of the upcoming
book the afghanistan papers published by
simon schuster a division of viacom cbs
whitlock says u.s officials knew for
years that the war was unwinnable and
misrepresented the situation to the
public
how did the military's private
assessments of these afghan forces
compared to what was being said publicly
about the situation in afghanistan day
after day week after week people at the
pentagon would stand up in public tell
reporters go on tv and say that you know
the afghan forces are coming along we're
building this army
you know it's slow going but they're
they're getting more capable and soon
they're going to be able to defend the
country but in private u.s military
trainers kept warning up the chain of
command that look these guys can't hit
the broad side of a barn the costs of
the war will continue for decades more
than 800 000 americans served in
afghanistan a harvard study finds health
care disability and other costs for
veterans of the afghanistan and iraq
wars will add up to another two trillion
dollars travis hoares with the iraq and
afghanistan veterans of america
they're going to need
health care for for their critical
wounds of war
for the rest of their lives and va must
properly ensure that they get that
health care for a wide swath of veterans
that are younger more diverse
than any other generation that's
happened before they started moving